[Music]
in today's eight on your side the back
to school shopping frenzy is in full
effect we caught up with mom of two and
money expert andrea warwick
she's got some great tips to get your
kids back to the classroom in style
without sacrificing your budget here's
the very first thing she says you should
do
before you even go shopping take a
minute take a step back and think about
what items you may have left over from
last year
that could work for this year your child
may have had a school backpack that
hardly got used
it's going to be perfectly good for this
year and if they fight you for a new one
just explain that the money saved on
that backpack
could go towards that new laptop or
maybe a pair of
name brand sneakers that your child is
wanting and that's one way to win your
fight
pick your battles after shopping at home
first the next tip
swap instead of buy trade your kids
clothing at swoondle society
join a buy nothing group for families on
facebook or start one for your own area
you can head to your local consignment
store to shop team fashion or check out
sites like poshmark
or thredup you can even find refurbished
tablets and laptops to help you save on
school tech needs but
do review the warranty details she says
and return policies before buying